We've done a lot of
work with two
equations and two unknowns.
And where each equation
and two variables
represents a line.
So you're just finding the
intersection of a line.
But what happens when you start
having three variables
in a linear equation?
So for example, let's say I had
x plus 4y plus z is equal
to, I don't know.
Let's say it's equal to 8.
So how do we think about this?
How do we think about it
visually, first of all?
Let's see if I can graph this.
So I like to draw my x- and
y-axes in the traditional
manner, then have the z-axis
popping in and out.
You'll see what I mean.
So that's my y-axis.
That is my x-axis.
And now my z-axis--
I can't make it.
Since this is a two-dimensional
format, it's
hard to do it, but I'll draw it
with a little perspective--
the z-axis, this is the back.
You can imagine this is
behind your screen.
And now I'm going in front of
our screen, or above our
screen, depending on how
you're viewing it.
So that's the z-axis.
That is the x-axis, and
that is the y-axis.
So you could almost view this
as a traditional x and y.
Now z tells us how-- if this was
your piece of paper-- how
much above the piece of paper we
are and how much behind the
piece of paper we are.
So we're now dealing in
three dimensions.
And now something to think
about-- and I'll answer it for
you in about two seconds-- is,
what does this represent in
three dimensions?
Does it represent a line
in three dimensions?
Or something else?
Well it turns out
that it actually
represents something else.
It represents a surface.
It represents-- and since the
coefficients are linear and
the-- not the coefficients--
since the variables are
linear, it represents a plane.
It would represent this big
curvy surface, if we had
squares in here and
all of that.
But we're dealing with
three-dimensional linear
equations, so this is just
going to be a plane.
And let's see if we
can visualize it.
The easiest way to draw this is
to figure out the various
intercepts, the various
axis intercepts.
So the x-intercept, the
y-intercept and now the
z-intercept.
Let's do the z-intercept first.
The z-intercept is when
x is equal to 0, y
is equal to 0.
What is z?
So if this is 0, this is
0, the z is equal to 8.
So that's this point
right here.
z is equal to 8.
Now what is the y-intercept?
That's when x is 0 and z is 0.
So if this is 0 and this
is 0, what's y?
4y is equal to 8, so y
would be equal to 2.
That would be right here.
That's 0, 2, 0.
0, 2, and then, no
z, 0 right there.
And then, finally, let's figure
out the x-intercept.
So y is 0 and z is 0, so if this
is 0 and this is 0, x is
going to be equal to 8.
So that is this right here.
Now, we could draw a line
connecting these.
And this wouldn't be necessarily
the graph, but
it'll help you visualize
the graph of the plane,
represented by this three
variable linear equation.
So let me do it in a really
light color, just so it
doesn't-- So up there.
And in most classes your teacher
will often view this
as the graph.
But you could kind of view
this-- this will be-- Let me
see if I can draw a little
bit of, just to
hit the point home.
This is a surface.
So if that's our surface, so
it would be the plane that
connects these three points.
And these lines right here, you
can kind of view them as
where this plane is intersecting
with this-- not
quadrant-- octant.
Because we have four cubic areas
in the back, you could
kind of say behind the page.
And we have four quadrants
above the page.
You can view it that way.
And so this is kind of the
intersection of this plane
with this top, right,
up octant.
Hopefully that doesn't
confuse you.
But it's important to keep
in mind that the
plane just keeps going.
And a plane in 3 dimensions is
defined by three points.
So that's why it's useful
to draw those three.
But this plane just keeps
going in each direction.
And this is the best that we
humans can do at graphing a
three variable linear equation
on a piece of paper.
I mean, it's a lot easier if you
could do it on a computer,
then you could rotate it, and
you could see it a lot better.
So what does it mean if you
have-- let's say you had two
equations like this.
Let's say you had this equation,
and then you had
let's say another equation.
Let's say you had, I don't
know, x plus y plus 3z is
equal to, I don't know,
is equal to 3.
So that graph, let's see, the
x-intercept, would be here.
It's going to be really
messy now.
The x-intercept is there at 3.
The y-intercept is at 3.
And then the z-intercept,
3z is equal to 3.
So the z-intercept's
going to be 1.
So if I were to attempt to draw
that plane-- at least in
this octant that I'm
participating in, and this
where it gets messy-- that plane
would look like that.
And it goes off in
every direction.
And now, if I had these two
equations, and I have three
unknowns, what is
the intersection
of these two equations?
Or what variables satisfy
these two equations?
So I hope you can
visualize it.
The intersection between this
green plane-- which represents
by this-- and our original
plane up here, is
going to be a line.
And that line is going to look
something like this.
They're going to intersect
right there.
There's going to be a line that
is in common between this
green plane and between
this blue equation,
or that blue plane.
And that might be really hard
to visualize, so don't worry
about it too much if you
find that confusing.
But this is the best
that I can do.
So as we can see, if we have
two equations and three
unknowns, the solution
is a line.
And a line has an infinite
number of points on it, so it
still doesn't help us much.
But it turns out, if we were to
throw in a third plane in
there, or a third equation.
And I don't know, maybe it's
minus x minus y minus z is
equal to 0.
That's going to be
something else.
It's going to be
harder to draw.
But now, this plane is going
to intersect this line.
Assuming it's not parallel to
one of the other two planes,
or it's not equal to one of
the other two planes, this
plane is going to intersect
the line that is the
intersection of this and this
plane, exactly one point.
So that's just a long winded
way of saying that three
planes that aren't the same
plane, and that aren't
parallel to each other,
will intersect
in exactly one point.
Or another way to put it, if
you want to solve for you a
unique x, y and z, your
constraints have to be three
variables, and three unknowns--
sorry-- three
equations with three unknowns.
So let's do one of them.
Let's see.
Image.
Actually, we're already
pushing eight minutes.
This video will be about
visualizing.
And then the next video, I'm
going to actually solve one.
I'll see you in the
next video.